this is why marketing is so dangerous
take a look at this video watch me
Rebrand mac and cheese to make it sound
like a Health Food Craft recently redid
their packaging I really like the
Simplicity of it but to make this seem
like a health food option we need to
make this look more like goles which
side note is very good I'm going to keep
this box blue because when you think of
craft mac and cheese you picture that
blue box but I don't just want this to
be a plain blue box so I'm going to add
my mac and cheese and put a beautiful
blue sky behind it to kind of blend that
blue background I don't want to
disrespect craft so I'll put their logo
at the top now instead of calling this
macaroni and cheese I'm going to rename
this and call this simple mac
technically this is a simple product
there's not a whole lot to it it's a
cheese powder and macaroni so it's
simple mac but that makes it seem like a
minimalistic kind of allnatural product
but I do feel like it needs a little bit
more so I'm going to add Farm to Fork on
there because frankly it doesn't mean
anything but again it makes it sound
more like an allnatural product and to
get a little bit more descriptive I will
add Farmhouse cheddar and macaroni
because using Farmhouse automatically
makes something sound healthier at the
bottom I'm going to add no artificial
flavors or preservatives because that's
actually what's on the box currently I'm
going to highlight 10 g of protein and z
g of trans fat and then I'm also going
to add made with real cheese and add a
little bit more cheese onto this
packaging because I mean this is
macaroni and cheese and that's all there
is to it there is our healthy craft
macaroni and cheese let me know what
else you want to see me turn into a Heth
food and I'll see what I can do
yikes you know what when I say marketing
is dangerous I don't mean all marketing
I'm saying this is where we can go if
we're not careful if we're simply
trusting the marketing it's probably
going to mislead us because their
incentives do not necessarily align with
my incentives and so shout out to Matt
rosenman he runs this account on
Instagram called cheat day design Des
there's one other video I wanted to
share with you and I thought maybe we
could have a conversation about it this
one so what he's doing here is he's
rebranding all of these unhealthy foods
to make them sound healthy so we feel
better about our purchase this one is
for cotton
candy watch me Rebrand cotton candy to
sound like a hell food cotton cand is a
challenging one because it's just sugar
but I have a direction to go instead of
calling it cotton candy because cand is
never going to sound healthy we're going
to call this fruit fluff this is not
flavored with real fruit but the flavors
resemble fruit so there's nothing
stopping us from calling it fruit fluff
and I want to really play into the
nature and Earth feel of this to make it
feel healthier so we'll give fruit fluff
a grassy background and then what I'm
going to do is add a tree with cotton
candy for the leaves and then to play
into the fruit theme a little bit more I
will add a bunch of roots with fruit
attached to it I know that all of this
fruit is not growing underground but it
looks good so get off my back and for
the brand that's selling this cotton
candy let's call it Nature's sweet this
is not a natural product but it's just
the brand name we could use nature in it
let's add fat free and sodium free which
both are true in cotton candy and I want
to add a very healthy sounding tagline
to this I'll say a lighter way to
satisfy Cravings from nature with love
the FDA does have regulations on using
the word light if you're talking about
nutrient claims this isn't a claim this
is just a light way to enjoy sweets and
sugar it's from nature technically and
with love of course this is made with
love and then really really super tiny
at the bottom we'll just say naturally
and artificially flavored because they
use both of them there she is there's
our healthy cotton candy let me know
what you think and as always challenge
me with your ideas for what I should
Rebrand into a health food next I'm so
hungry right now I'm so
mad Mal you know what's fascinating
about this is I see that and it would in
a weird way make me feel better about
the purchase for both of these he did
another one for candy corn and he does
these all the time and that's why I
really like what he's exposing he's by
the way not telling you you should or
shouldn't eat cotton candy he's not
saying you should or shouldn't eat
macaroni and cheese what he's showing
you is that the marketing of a thing is
often considerably different from the
thing itself and there are um two
versions of this by the way he touches
on one and that is the tendency to
embrace something as good just because
it is presented in a way that's poetic
or picturesque the other is to the
tendency to reject something as bque BS
just because it's presented in a way
that's poetic or picturesque and both of
those things are real there are people
who will reject something just because
it sounds pretty and they've been sort
of conditioned to be suspicious of
anything that sounds pretty oh that must
be fluff that must be BS so both of
these things work but I love what he's
doing because it is funny and it
encourages critical thinking in a way
that people are going to find
entertaining and easy to pay attention
to it's a constant reminder that the
frame around things affects the way you
look at it and so beware of ways in
which you are being duped into
dismissing things or embracing things
because of the frame but also pay
attention to the way in which you can
use this power for good what areas of
your life actually are nutritious
actually are edifying but you've got a
terrible frame around it that isn't
highlighting so I like to think about it
from both sides in that way but I love
what he's doing I mean great wakeup call
to people in in an interesting way great
example of how to teach critical
thinking without putting people to sleep
oh yeah and I've fallen for the farm to
Fork nonsense before I looked at that
and was like oh my gosh he's right I
fell for that stuff it made me feel
better because I like well if it's it's
processed but like H it's a little bit
better because it's like farm raised or
whatever and I that's a story I was tell
telling myself about stuff right The
Farmhouse cheddar like that sounds
healthier than just saying powdered
cheese obviously right or hey is soy
free vegan yeah low sodium or whatever
it is and it's like well of course
there's there are no trans fats in
cotton candy right I want to say of
course but maybe not of course these
days let's just inject all the poisons
into the food we did that with uh Dr
Zack Bush recently we watched that video
of the guy like you know what let's just
put poison in the food it'll save us
money right and I think that's what
we're doing here and so mallerie what
you're bringing up is like all of these
marketing terms quite often are
literally nonsense they're nonsensical
and it makes me start to question and
this is where the critical thinking
comes into play that TK is talking about
it makes me question what other nonsense
am I falling for what other Farm to fork
or other marketing terms sound Noble or
sound healthy that actually are just
nonsensical marketing terms that are
meant to divorce me from the money in my
bank account yeah you know when you
watch superhero movies and you look at
the superhero and the villain they are
both expressions of Genius creativity
and admirable potential and they use
them for two different purposes right
and creativity is it's neutral it's a
it's a form of power right and you can
use that for good you can use it for ill
you can use it to deceive people exploit
them and manipulate them or you can use
it to take things that are truly
beautiful and frame them in such a way
so that people will want more of what's
good for them and so I'm definitely a
champion of studying things like this so
that we can become students of how to
use these things for good I hope you
enjoy that highlight if you like to see
another one check out this video right
here if you like to see that full
episode check out this video here or if
you'd like to dive deep into the full
private podcast subscribe via the
patreon link in the description your
support on patreon is what allows us to
keep this podcast 100% advertisement
free